[Musique]
bonjour je m'appelle nathalie nourrit
chez 44 on est je vous invite à
découvrir kazan
[Musique]
casino c'est une boutique atelier
loisirs créatifs et bauza qui accueille
des enfants et des adultes du lundi au
samedi pour des ateliers de peinture des
ateliers de loisirs créatifs ou qui vont
développer chez eux toute leur
créativité
donc dans des domaines très variés on a
aussi un système de navettes qui
récupère les enfants à l'école pour les
emmener le soir en atelier et puis le
petit plus c'est l'atelier coiffure ou
quand les parents sont en atelier les
enfants veulent se faire boiter et vice
versa j'ai créé kazan ou en moins d'un
an
j'ai pu faire aboutir ce projet on a eu
des emplois qui ont été créés donc trois
personnes dont deux à plein temps au
niveau de la capacité de l'accueil on en
a qui a levé 5
aujourd'hui on accueille cinq fois plus
avec un espace comme celui là on va
enrichir encore la gamme d'activités que
ce soit en beaux-arts ou aux loisirs et
je pense que cassano est un très bel
exemple de performance j'ai travaillé
pendant plus de 15 ans en tant
qu'assistante de direction
g
tu es dans une société où il ya eu un
plan social et puis je me suis fait
aider par des organismes tels que
réunion active réunion entreprendre le
crédit agricole a suivi également le
projet en tant que chef d'entreprise ça
m'apporte une grande liberté
je fais exactement ce que j'aime et je
n'ai pas du tout l'impression de
travailler au niveau de l'estiment de
soi c'est important parce qu'on se dit
on arrive à se réaliser
on arrive à réaliser un rêve pour voir
le sourire des enfants les voir grandir
les voir s'épanouir
ça c'est que du bonheur alors je vais
gagner le challenge the creator parce
que je me suis inscrite pour le gagner
et puis parce que ça serait vraiment une
réelle reconnaissance du travail
accompli et de la performance accomplie
ces deux dernières années bonjour
michael richard 47 ans gérant de l2
mairie
notre activité concerne le
reconditionnement d'ordinateurs et de
téléphones dans l'océan indien et plus
particulièrement à la région leur
conditionnement est une démarche de
développement durable qui vise à
réemployer les produits plutôt qu'à les
détruire c'est une démarche à laquelle
elle de herri s'associent pleinement
notamment sur une île qui tient à coeur
au patrimoine mondial cette activité à
la réunion à moins de deux ans nous
avons créé au total sept emplois directs
et 13 emplois indirects
cette année nous allons culture avec
5000 clients qui nous ont fait confiance
aujourd'hui nous avons 8 % du marché des
produits électroniques à la réunion
cette année pour notre deuxième bilan
nous devrions clôturer un million huit
cent mille euros
j'ai passé onze ans dans l'immobilier
comme dirigeant de nécessité dont cinq
ans à la réunion j'ai profité d'une
transition professionnelle de demandes
d'emploi j'étais chômeurs bénéficiaires
de dollars et je me suis tourné vers
initiative réunion entreprendre qui m'a
permis de récupérer le premier capital
pour démarrer cette entreprise c'est une
immense satisfaction de voir quelque
chose qui est abstrait devenir une
réalité de créer des emplois nous sommes
sur le point de démarrer à l'export
cette activité à l'humoriste et sur
lequel nous avons de bons espoirs
le sentiment de créer de la valeur j'en
suis très heureux je vais gagner le
challenge créateurs d'entreprises dans
la catégorie performant pour trois
raisons principalement la première avec
tina et donc économique en termes de
performances de chiffre d'affaires nous
allons clôturer à 2 millions de
créations d'emplois de créer dix emplois
cette année
la deuxième raison c'est la confiance de
nos clients
la troisième raison c'est que nous
luttons contre l'obsolescence programmée
l'avenir c'est l'économie circulaire
pour sauver la planète car un produit
recyclé est un achat à responsable et
c'est aussi une performance
[Musique]